[Applaus]
[Musik]
habt ihr schon mal was von der in israel
entwickelten spionagesoftware pegasus
gehört
[Musik]
ich bin sicher dass viele von euch schon
so einiges über jenes gespenstische
applaus ist ihm zu ohren gekommen ist
geschichten wie die des journalisten
jamal k shogi der 2018 durch saudi
arabien im vorfeld seiner liquidierung
mithilfe genau dieser von der
israelischen firma sv group entwickelten
software ausspioniert worden war dies
wurde zwar seitens eines au grob immer
wieder bestritten konnte aber im rahmen
des so genannten pegasus projekt an dem
mehr als 80 journalisten von 17
medienorganisationen aus zehn ländern
beteiligt waren bewiesen werden
und eines könnt ihr mir glauben die
schlussfolgerungen dieser untersuchung
werden euch die nackenhaare zu berge
stehen lassen
private israelische spionage software
wollen dass du genutzt um weltweit
handys von journalisten und aktivisten
zu hacken das bildungsprojekt stück sich
dabei auf daten und einer geliebten
liste mit rund 50.000 telefonnummern
welche von verschiedenen regierungen
hilfe der israelischen software
ausspioniert wurden
die untersuchung stützt sich dabei
direkt an die regierungen von zehn
verschiedenen ländern die diese software
angeblich missbraucht haben um
journalisten und oppositionelle und
politische aktivisten unkontrolliert zu
überwachen und zu verfolgen an ist
dieser länder ist eben saudi arabien und
ja unter den ausspionierten nummern war
auch die von kazuki die seiner frau und
die einiger seiner kontaktpersonen passt
auf den gesprächen hier auch von
spionage auf allerhöchster ebene
[Musik]
ihr wisst zum beispiel dass indien
pakistan zwei atommächte sind die man
nicht gerade als beste freunde
bezeichnen kann nicht war okay dann
schaut euch mal folgendes an pakistan
mischt sich in den pegasus streit ein es
wird in den vor ihm rang an
auszuspionieren und fordert eine
un-untersuchung imran khan ist dabei
niemand anderes als der damalige
premierminister von pakistan und
natürlich ist die indische regierung
eben eine jeder den regierungen die das
projekt im visier hat aber diese
geschichte geht noch viel weiter ich
versichere euch dass viele von euch nach
diesem video agenten-thriller aller
james bond jason bourne oder v da mit
ganz anderen augen sehen werden doch wie
funktioniert diese überwachungssoftware
picassos und wofür genau wurde sie
einsetzt ist die einsatz eine gute oder
eine schlechte sache und wie hat die
neue israelische regierung auf die
enthüllungen und skandale rund um das
pegasus projekt reagiert in diesem video
werden wir all diese fragen natürlich
klären und da es hier um das thema
sichere kommunikation geht da ist nicht
viel genau ein hinweis darauf wie auch
ihr eure kommunikation im netz absichern
könnte na habt ihr da eine idee wie ihr
schon so stark wie pianist sichere vpn
welches dieses und auch viele andere
unserer videos finanziell unterstützt
und somit erst möglich gemacht hat und
wisst ihr was wir machen sehr gerne da
wo für search ab denn im gegensatz zu
vielen er und seriöse sponsoren wie auf
anderen youtube-kanäle unwesen treiben
von uns jedoch reihenweise abgelehnt
werden handelt es sich bei surft man
angebot das ich auch persönlich in
anspruch nehmen ohne bedenken
weiterempfehlen kann aber was bringt
euch ein vpn eigentlich nur zum einen
erschwertes allen möglichen leuten und
angreifern über behörden bis zu
werbetreibenden eure aktionen im netz
nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören ein
pegasus kann es nicht stoppen aber
vieles andere ist bietet unzählige
sicherheits features mit denen ihr eure
anonymität und abhörsicherheit indes
erhöht zum beispiel clean web dass alle
cookies pop absolut auch
fortgeschrittene identifizierung zur
nachverfolgung es muss sicher bloggt und
die damit verbundenen gefahren beseitigt
ein weiterer vorteil dieses europa ist
also tun könnte als wäre die an einem
anderen ort und verscharrt bietet er
eine ganze latte von servern in vielen
verschiedenen ländern an so könnt ihr
zum beispiel auch webseiten und internet
dienste zugreifen im land in dem wir
gerade verfügbar sind ohne zensur und
giro blocking ob daheim oder in urlaub
netflix und andere streaming dienste die
ihre inhalte nur den usa anbieten von
europa aus nutzen mit softer kein
problem aber das ist noch lange nicht
alles denn mit nur einem soft control
könnt ihr wirklich alle endgeräte
info-point registrieren handys notebooks
oder sogar als htv so bekommt ihr einen
lückenlosen schutz und ihr wisst ja nur
der paranoide überlebt so und wenn ihr
den rabattcode politik.de angebt bekommt
ihr von surfer auf einer party in höhe
von 83 prozent und obendrein die ersten
drei monate gratis dazu den links zu
diesem angebot findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter diesem video also
nichts wie los besorgt und greift damit
uns finanziell unter die arme das könnt
ihr übrigens auch direkt mit hilfe des
paypal spenden links nicht euch
ebenfalls in die beschreibung gepackt
haben wir sind euch für jede
unterstützung dankbar denn damit hätten
wir uns auch in zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere videos zu liefern so und
nun zurück zu picassos anfragen weil sie
wie so oft beantworten wollen indem wir
zunächst einen kurzen blick in die
geschichte werfen
[Musik]
wenn ihr den bond-film sektor gesehen
habt werdet ihr auch daran erinnern dass
sich die nebenhandlung des films punkt
ein massives spionage programm mit dem
namen nay nice dreht in diesem film
verhandelt die neuen großmächte der welt
über die umsetzung des abkommens zur
terrorismusbekämpfung mithilfe totaler
überwachung nun es scheint dass ein
ingenieur der sv group in israel den
film gesehen haben muss und anschließend
dachte das müsste doch zu machen sein
dann mal ran an die arbeit
die neuesten technologischen
entwicklungen der nsu group ermöglichen
den zugriff auf private telefone durch
zero klick angriffe das heißt dass
spionage opfer muss noch nicht mal einen
bösartigen link oder ähnliches öffnen um
in die fänge dieser software zu geraten
außerdem kann der zahlende kunde ab dem
moment in dem das telefon mit pegasus
infiziert ist die vollständige kontrolle
über das gerät übernehmen so kann er
beispielsweise die nachrichten fotos und
e mails im telefon auslesen und
gegebenenfalls auch manipulieren
außerdem kann er eure anrufe aufzeichnen
heimlich eure kameras oder mikrofone
aktivieren und die inhalte und
verschließen messaging apps wie gossip
telegramm oder signal mitlesen
um an lost konversation heranzukommen
hat die israelische firma ein programm
entwickelt mit denen sie den netzwerk
sagt er in der anwendung präzise
emulieren konnte auf diese weise konnten
sie schadcode übertragen der von den
webservern nicht erkannt wurde und es
seht euch nur die reaktion des
allmächtigen facebook bzw heutigen meter
konzerns an als er diese machenschaften
aufdeckten whatsapp beschuldigt und
verklagt den hersteller der handys bei
wmf gruppe regen zero day anrufen diese
klage wurde im oktober 2009 eingereicht
fast zwei jahre bevor der skandal um das
pegasus projekt bekannt wurde damals gab
an dass das israelische unternehmen
versucht hatte mindestens 1400 nutzer zu
hacken diese sollte ein weckruf für
technologie unternehmen regierungen und
alle internetnutzer seien werkzeuge
welche die überwachung unseres
privatlebens ermöglichen werden
missbraucht und die verbreitung dieser
technologie in den händen von
unverantwortlichen unternehmen und
regierungen regens alle in gefahr
burkard chef von sap tatsache ist dass
sich unter den rund 50.000
telefonnummern auf der von pegasus
projekt untersuchten liste viele pro
demokratische aktivisten geschäftsleute
persönlichkeiten des öffentlichen lebens
und zahlreiche führende politiker
befinden oft natürlich gegner der
jeweiligen regierung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und wenn das nicht schon sehr ernst
klingt wie stellt euch vor wie
gefährlich ist sein kann als journalist
in einem land wie mexiko einer wahren
hölle für die pressefreiheit
ausspioniert zu werden nun ihr müsst es
euch nicht vorstellen denn das ist schon
geschehen hier ist zum beispiel der fall
von cecile you pineda ein 2017
ermordeter mexikanische journalist wurde
zuvor von der pegasus software
ausspioniert ein feature von pegasus
besteht nämlich darin dass durch den
zugriff auf die sensoren des telefons
auch die bewegung in einer person
aufgezeichnet und der standort in
echtzeit fast punktgenau verfolgt werden
kann und auf diese weise wurde das trio
pineda in einer autowaschanlage getötet
nachdem ein mexikanischer kunde von seo
es eine woche vorher auf ihn abgesehen
hatte und ihr könnt euch sicher denken
was nie gefunden wurde richtig seine
telefone
[Musik]
tatsächlich war mexiko das land in dem
die meisten telefonnummern mit diesem
system ausspioniert würden zumindest
laut der veröffentlichten liste es ist
zum beispiel bekannt dass während der
regierung peña nieto mehrere
regierungsbehörden pegasus verwendet
haben die rede ist von mehr als 15.000
mobiltelefon unter den personen waren
nicht nur kriminelle sondern zahlreiche
journalisten aktivisten und führende
politiker wie da schließt was in der
derzeitige präsident andrés manuel lópez
obrador
und diese situation wird noch viel
schlimmer wenn man sich den fall von
thomas krohn anschaut die rede ist von
einem mann der als schlüsselfigur
innerhalb der regierung benaglio galt
und über den kauf von
überwachungstechnologien durch die
regierung entschied ein mann der dach
bis 15.000 mexikaner ohne richterliche
genehmigung auszuspionieren sei eine
tolle sache
[Musik]
und genau dieser beamte dort seit jahren
wegen unregelmäßigkeiten bei den
ermittlungen im fall der massen führung
in idealer im jahr 2014 besucht bei der
43 studenten die einfach nur zur
falschen zeit am falschen ort waren über
nacht verschwanden und später ermordet
wurden thomas sehr rauen spielte nämlich
eine entscheidende rolle beide fast
durchführung dieser geschehnisse tja und
jetzt scheint es dass um seine
geschäftskontakte sehr zugutegekommen
sind der von der mexikanischen justiz
gesuchte thomas ist er ohne sucht
zuflucht in israel die lsv group sind
natürlich dass die software nur an
regierungen und sicherheitsbehörde in 40
ländern verkauft wurde um verbrechen und
terroranschläge zu verhindern aber genau
hier liegt die gefahr bei pegasus
natürlich darin was passiert wenn das
ganze eben die falschen hände gerät das
israelische unternehmen versichert zwar
vehement dass es die menschenrechtslage
seine kunden prüft bevor es ihnen
software verkauft es hat sogar auszüge
aus verträgen mit seinen kunden
veröffentlicht in dem festgelegt ist
dass sie ihre produkte klose
ermittlungen im bereich kriminalität und
nationale sicherheit verwenden dürfen
aber papier ist bekannterweise geduldig
und sobald die software verkauft und
einsatzbereit ist hat die erste group
natürlich keine kontrolle mehr darüber
wie und wozu genau sie eingesetzt wird
und es ist vollkommen klar dass viele
regierungen überhaupt nicht die absicht
hatten ihre verträge mit der eu
einzuhalten aber ich denke jetzt ist die
richtige zeit zu erfahren welche
regierung genau vom dk das projekt ins
visier genommen wurden und welche
enthüllungen dabei ans licht der
öffentlichkeit gekommen sind also hört
gut zu
[Musik]
liebesgrüße aus rabatt
am anfang des videos haben sie zum
beispiel von verbindungen zwischen der
pegasus software saudi arabien erzählt
eine verbindung die als teil des kampfes
gegen den iran ihren großen gemeinsamen
feind gesehen werden kann aber liebe
fußball politik fans das ist noch nicht
alles die untersuchung weist direkt
darauf wenn die die gas von den
sunnitischen monaten genutzt wird mit
dem israel welche überraschung vor
kurzem seine diplomatischen beziehungen
normalisiert hat die rede ist natürlich
von bachrain marokko und den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten tatsächlich
vervollständigen die beiden
letztgenannten ländern das podium jeder
herrscher die mit pegasus die meisten
telefone ausspioniert haben und wieder
einmal ist das größte problem sowohl für
israel als auch für die so klug dass sie
nicht wissen können was ihre kunden
letztendlich im schilde führen projekte
also dass emanuel markus mobiltelefon
von marokko angezapft diejenigen von
euch die visual politik regelmäßig
verfolgen werden sich zum beispiel an
unsere video über den algerischen
ricanischen erdgas krieg erinnern darin
haben wir euch davon berichtet dass im
auto mit der israelischen software
tausenden und telefon aus geräte von
denen die meisten der algerischen elite
gehören
[Musik]
ich werde euch dieses video natürlich
verlinken falls ihr es noch nicht
gesehen haben sollten und schließlich
wurde peters ist auch noch von ein paar
guten freunden benjamin netanyahu
ausgenutzt gespräche in diesem fall von
den regierungen brasiliens ungarns und
indiens und auch die von aserbaidschan
kasachstan und ruanda die allesamt nicht
gerade als vorzeige länder wirklich
demokratie menschenrechte und
meinungsfreiheit gelten vor diesem
hintergrund scheint es dass
vereinbarungen zur cyber überwachung
eine der wichtigsten 501 jahres bei
verhandlungen mit ausländischen
staatsoberhäuptern waren ja in der
politik muss man eben nicht alles zur
verhandlungsmasse machen um mehr macht
zu gewinnen aber man kann es verstehen
haben ergeben dass die ungarische
regierung von viktor orban pegasus in
ihrem sogenannten krieg gegen die medien
einsetzt und dabei unter anderem
investigativer journalisten abgehört hat
natürlich gibt es auch länder in dem die
journalisten noch schlechter geht wie
zum beispiel marokko da gibt es zum
beispiel den fall des derzeit
inhaftierten oma die aber nur um es noch
einmal klarzustellen wir reden hier
nicht über ein zweitrangiges problem
dass ein schlichter und schikanieren von
kritikern ist pegasus einfach billiger
und totaler als jemals zuvor geworden
schließlich hat die digitalisierung ja
auch dafür gesorgt dass viel sicherer
kommuniziert werden kann im analogen
zeitalter war es quasi unmöglich sich
vor dem abhören von telefonaten oder den
abfangen von briefen zu schützen die
behörden hatten zumindest aus
technischer sicht den vollen zugriff
sowohl in den vermittlungsstellen als
auf den postämtern zwar war die
massenüberwachung schwieriger aber
angriffe viel einfacher als heute durch
heutige möglichkeiten der ende zu ende
verschlüsselung über alle möglichen
protokolle von https über ip telefonie
bis hin zu messengern risiken haben
behörden meist jedoch keine chance an
die nachrichten oder gesprächsinhalte zu
gelangen so lange sie nicht direkt auf
die endgeräte zugriff erlangen
[Musik]
kriminelle terroristen und alle anderen
möglichen düsteren gestalten können
daher fast etwas von der materie
verstehen und ihre endgeräte schützen zu
ungestört kommunizieren wie nie zuvor da
es ist klar das geheimnis der
sicherheitsbehörden wenn sich nichts
ändert diese art von software weiterhin
nutzen werden um das gleichgewicht
wieder etwas zu ihren gunsten zu
verschieben auch das deutsche bka war
pegasus allerdings angeblich nur in
einer abgespeckten version in der
bestimmte funktionen gesperrt sind um
missbrauch zu verhindern wollen wir mal
hoffen dass das stimmt denn manchmal
kann es auch passieren dass man mit
hilfe einer solchen mächtigen
überwachungs waffe am ende einen staat
im staate erschafft was ich damit meine
nun schaut euch mal folgendes an projekt
picassos der könig von marokko uns ein
gefolge auf der liste der potenziellen
spionage ziele nur einen monat bevor der
skandal um das pegasus projekt publik
wurde kam es in israel bildung einer
neuen regierung womit die ära netanjahu
vorerst zu ende gehen der punkt ist dass
sich die neue exekutive in einer überaus
angespannten lage wieder erfand das
israelische gesetz zur kontrolle von
verteidigungsexperten aus dem jahr 2007
verlangt nämlich das unternehmen ein
strenges genehmigungsverfahren
durchlaufen es wurde verabschiedet
nachdem sich die usa beschwert hatten
dass israel waffen an china verkauft
aber natürlich wenn man sich ansieht was
danach passiert ist sieht es nicht so
aus als ob die israelischen kontrollen
wirklich effektiv gewesen wären und so
langsam beginnt man das auch in israel
zu begreifen sogar innerhalb der
regierung selbst
laut dem minister für diaspora
angelegenheiten schadet der nsu
spionage-skandal den diplomatischen
interessen israels okay wie soll man ist
nicht gerade der wichtigste minister in
der exekutive
immerhin besteht die acht parteien
koalitionsregierung israels aus sage und
schreibe 27 ministerien damit ja keiner
zu kurz kommt aber hey eine von ihnen
hat das problem immerhin schon
angesprochen
übrigens die veröffentlichung der
enthüllungen des pegasus projekt war ein
direkter schlag für diego co und zwar
nicht nur für das unternehmen selbst
wenn ihr hauptanteilseigner ist seit
anfang 2009 10 uhr ort pina capital ein
britisches private equity unternehmen
das eine mehrheitsbeteiligung an der
israelischen firma erworben hat die
implizite bewertung der transaktion
brachte die nsu krupp damals in den
exklusiven club der sogenannten
einhörner das heißt dass start ups die
einen wert von mehr als einer milliarde
dollar erreichen nun unter spionage
skandal hat auch die anteilseigner
wachgerüttelt us berater stehen schlange
um den vor zu leiten denen das
israelische spionage unternehmen denn es
gehört der größte investor von norbert
pina capital ist niemand anderes als der
öffentliche pensionsfonds des
amerikanischen bundesstaates oregon ein
vor dessen manager sich jetzt große
sorgen um die zukunft der investitionen
machen und um die altersversorgung der
bonner beamten die hauptfrage ist jedoch
was die israelische regierung zu tun
gedenkt nun genau das nehmen wir jetzt
etwas genauer unter die lupe
[Musik]
leben und sterben lassen
israels cybersicherheit branche boomt
wie nie zuvor laut der
risikokapitalfirma ventures haben
israelische startups im jahr 2021 die
rekordzahl von fast 9 9 milliarden
dollar eingesammelt außerdem wurden nun
unternehmer aus dem hebräischen land in
den erlesenen club der globalen
einhörner aufgenommen der erfolg dieser
branche erstreckt sich auch auf die
politische arena die neue israelische
regierung hat enge verbindungen zur
cybersicherheit das spielte nsu trug
natürlich in die hände der derzeitige
ministerpräsident nach taliban at wurde
zum beispiel zum multimillionär indem er
das von ihm gegründete und auf dem
bankensektor spezialisierte online
sicherheitsunternehmens toyota verkaufte
aber wie sich herausstellt ist bennet
nicht der einzige
alex kidd benetzt rechte hand und
derzeitige innenministerin ist eine
software ingenieure die in der
hightech-industrie von tel aviv karriere
gemacht hat und sie ist auch eine enge
freundin von schiri dollar der
präsidentin der nsv group der
verteidigungsminister general ade wenig
glanz war präsident von 50 menschen in
einem unternehmen das sich auf das
aufspüren von smartphones durch spionage
programm für die polizei und auf
terrorismusbekämpfung spezialisiert hat
[Musik]
für die menschen gibt es heute nicht
mehr aber ein anderer mann aus der
führungsetage der firma und früher sogar
wo ist hier beim osram will barak ist
derzeit vorsitzender des verteidigungs
und außenausschusses des israelischen
parlaments das ist genau jene ausschuss
der für die überwachung der cyber
exporte des landes zuständig ist
[Musik]
wie ihr seht sie die verbindungen
zwischen den privaten cyber
sicherheitssektor und öffentlichen
einrichtungen sehr eck das was also
anfang november bringt die israelische
regierung in eine sehr unangenehme lage
die usa setzten die israelische firma
nsu group wegen der verwendung von
spionage-software auf die schwarze liste
es handelt sich um dieselbe schwarze
liste von handelssanktionen auf der auch
das große chinesische unternehmen huawei
steht und das ganze bedeutet dass die
verwendung von us technologie in den
produkten der ns-opfer absolut verboten
ist aber die reaktion der israelischen
regierung auf die picasso software ba
die gleiche wie immer man versprach
sicherzustellen dass alle israelischen
cyber exporte von der regierung
übereinstimmung mit internationalen
vereinbarungen geregelt werden dies
wurde auch von ihrer rede betont dem
derzeitigen außenminister der nach den
vereinbarungen der regierungskoalition
turnusgemäß israels nächster
ministerpräsident werden wird der
contractmanager
allen kontinenten
der schritt der beiden regierung hatte
jedoch direkte folgen für nsu die
ratingagentur moody's stufte das
unternehmen auf ramschniveau herab
laut der ratingagentur ist die ns-opfer
in hohem maße vom verkauf neuer lizenzen
für seine software abhängig was
angesichts der maßnahmen der usa immer
schwieriger zu erreichen sein wird der
schlechte nachrichten also für oregon
rentner
israels eines group droht nach der
aufnahme auf die schwarze liste der usa
ein zahlungsausfall von 50 millionen
dollar und ein unternehmen das dns
gruppe wegen ausspionierens von nutzern
ihre geräte verklagt hat ist niemand
geringeres als apple es wurde sogar
bekannt dass ns pegasus das iphone des
preisgekrönten regierungskritischen
jordanischen journalisten cj gehackt hat
selbst wochen nachdem apple eine
einstweilige verfügung erwirkt hatte die
ist im unternehmen verbieten würde
iphone nutzer ins visier zu nehmen aber
der internationale druck wächst wir
sprechen hier über einen der vielleicht
größten fehltritte der israelischen
außen sicherheits und technologiepolitik
trotzdem ist es überraschend dass kaum
etwas unternommen sagt aber wartet ein
momentan achtzehnter januar 2022 kam
eine bahnbrechende nachricht als nicht
die alles ändern könnte
die israelische polizei nutzt nss
pegasus um bürger auszuspionieren unter
den opfern scheint einige bürgermeister
und politische aktivisten sowie
ehemalige regierungsmitarbeiter zu sein
berichten zufolge wollten sie
ausspioniert ohne das ein
durchsuchungsbefehl oder eine ups vorlag
welche die überwachung legitimiert hätte
am ersten februar gab die israelische
polizei dazu dass die software von ihr
tatsächlich schwer missbräuchlich
genutzt wurde ein weiterer catalis
bericht enthüllte dass die überwachung
ohne richterliche anordnung in israel
sehr weit verbreitet war einschließlich
der überwachung von politikern und
regierungsbeamten unternehmenschefs
journalisten aktivisten und sogar aber
netanyahu demission des damaligen
premierministers benjamin netanjahu
sogar der derzeitige polizeipräsident
selbst fordert nun einen staatlichen
untersuchungsausschuss israel muss jetzt
also handeln
und deswegen entschied der minister für
öffentliche sicherheit um mehr bar lässt
dass ein umfassender
untersuchungsausschuss unter dem vorsitz
eines unabhängigen pensionierten
richters eingesetzt wird dessen
befugnisse denen eines staatlichen
ausschusses entsprechen die technologie
schreitet voran und verbessert unser
leben der beitrag israels zu dieser
entwicklung ist einfach beeindruckend
aber manchmal können die dinge eben aus
dem ruder laufen und alles sieht nach
einer riesigen schwachstelle in den
sicherheitsprotokoll der hightech nation
aus immerhin des einzigen demokratischen
staates im nahen osten schließlich
scheint es nicht die beste idee zu sein
solch eine software in die hände jener
person nun starten zu geben die wir euch
in diesem video gezeigt haben nicht wahr
jetzt ist nur zu hoffen dass israel
seinen pegasus saustall endlich
ausmistet es ist höchste zeit aber jetzt
sind die fragen an euch gerichtet was
denkt ihr wie israel mit der pegasus
software umgehen sollte wird es der
stadt schaffen die balance zwischen
seinen technischen fähigkeiten und der
sich daraus ergebenden verantwortung in
bezug auf demokratische werte wieder
herzustellen was haltet ihr von pegasus
einsatz in eurem land und in der eu wie
immer sind auf eure beiträge und
diskussionen zu diesem thema schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat und ich glaube auch
dass gelernt habt falls ja geht es mir
dann leichter zu werden freunde und
vergesst nicht das abo mit glöckchen
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich folgen und auch jederzeit über
eine spende von euch mit er als held
dieses projekt weiterzuführen
peter link dazu findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter dem video was gut und
bis bald
[Musik]